president Trump ended TPS or temporary
protected status for Salvadorans who up
until now have been able to live and
work in the US legally they got the
status in 2001 after devastating
earthquakes hit their country but now
nearly 200,000 Salvadorans will have to
go back to their country by September
2019 and for some it could be a matter
of life and death I'm about to visit
Jose whose health will be in jeopardy if
his family has to leave
[Music]
Jose is 23 he came to the u.s. from El
Salvador when he was nine he's battled
leukemia since he was 15 and recently
relapsed for the third time leukemia was
found in my spinal fluid and in my brain
so I relapsed yet again and I'm gonna do
a treatment called car T which will
genetically modify my own cells to fight
the cancer and it's a real chance attic
care so you're just waiting to go back
to the hospital it could be any day now
yeah I'm just waiting for my insurance
to approve the treatment and go back to
the hospital and start the treatment but
that's where the problem lies when
looking at the family's uncertain future
Jose has daca and his parents are under
temporary protected status he's covered
under his mother's private health
insurance if your mom's TPS status is
terminated your health is in real
jeopardy yeah and there's there's a lot
of kids that are in my situation I just
think yeah my health is in jeopardy I
would lose my insurance and I would I
don't know what I would do at that point
because parents is the reason why I'm
here today like I had my bone marrow
transplant that her insurance she was
actually my donor so my mom's just has
fought really hard for me to be alive
Jose attends college and works part-time
at school but he doesn't have enough
hours to get health insurance his mother
left El Salvador in 2001 just after two
devastating earthquakes killed 1200
people and left another 1 million
homeless his father left in 1996 several
years after a 12-year civil war tore the
country apart during that war the US
assisted a right-wing Salvadoran
government that used army-backed death
squads to kill tens of thousands
so your parents have benefited from
their temporary production status for a
number of years now yeah my mom has had
it for 15 and with outside it for 20 how
did they feel how did you all feel when
you heard that the Trump administration
is going to end it it was hard I think
it was hard for them to hear that and it
was also hard for me the uncertainty you
know you hear about my status being
disgusted and like the American American
public really supports it like 80
percent eighty to ninety percent really
want something for the the dreamers kids
but you never hear anyone talked about
temporary protective status and you know
they're older than older population
there they came here straight to work
like my mom told me like I asked her
like how do you feel like you know we're
older we came here to work and we're not
as marketable as you guys are and it's
sad to hear people think about each
other as marketable or like whether
you're worthy or not despite the popular
support for daca recipients Jose still
gets his share of online hate so when I
was in the hospital last time a lot of
stories that I did Kate that I
interviewed that I that four came out
simultaneously while I had to be
impatient they were listing the hospital
I was in and like people were like we
need to find out hospital is in so we
can call eyes and it was a real safety
concern at that point and I had to let
the hospital know and they like
basically erased erased my name so if
anybody called they wouldn't say that I
was at the hospital it doesn't matter
that I have that God doesn't matter that
my parents have temporary protection
doesn't matter that my mom works her ass
off to get private insurance all of that
goes above their head and the first
thing is let's call ice
[Music]
Jose's grandmother has told him it's not
safe to return to their old neighborhood
in El Salvador because the US has
deported gang members back to the area
so the government in determining that
TPS should end said we look at El
Salvador and we've determined that it's
safe for folks to go back now what do
you say to them they they pulled out
their piece court from El Salvador how
did that determination
came about that Americans are not safe
in El Salvador but somehow these other
people are so the US has really metal
within my
country and its really like a byproduct
of the US policies that El Salvador's
not a safe place right now for me
hearing that my doc I was certain that I
mean like I would be forced to go to a
country that's homophobic and would not
protect me doesn't protect trans rights
we have no protection under there and
it's and the homophobia is really strong
and people often get killed how do you
think the Trump administration views
someone like you I think the current
administration looked at someone like me
not well they want to like use my status
as a bargaining chip
like hey like listen we'll give you this
if you give me 24 billion for a while
and I benefit from the Affordable Health
Care and we all know that really I'm a
queer man who has a pre-existing
condition like that I'm gonna make
ramble documented a hate
in addition to battling leukemia right
now there are so many things up in the
air in your life how do you explain how
you even feel it's it's odd I think
we're undocumented immigrants we we just
kind of like show up that's what we do
like we just my parents inflicted a
really really good work ethic so when I
was going through high school like I
finished my high school while doing
treatment think I was puking and reading
books and then like I went back to
college two months right after my
transplant was done so it's not like you
just go ahead and follow life and hope
for the best
hi everyone its Tina and Jose stories
just one example of so many immigrant
families whose future is in limbo check
out more of our reporting in the direct
from playlist and please like comment
share and subscribe to AJ Plus